here is Tucker going after Ben Shapiro
this is just a couple days ago there are
people on the right who have spent the
last 2 months every single day focused
on a conflict in a foreign country as
our own country becomes dangerously
unstable on the brink of financial
collapse with tens of millions of people
who shouldn't be here in the country we
don't know their identities or the
purpose of their being here like stuff
that's could destroy the country for
real and make it impossible for my kids
to live here they don't care about the
country at all and that's you know
that's kind of their prerogative but I
do like I I'm shocked by how little they
care about the country and including the
person you mentioned and I I can't
imagine how someone like that could get
an audience of people who claimed about
care about America cuz he doesn't the
idea that Ben Shapiro does not care
about America nor has been like
basically the number one conservative
voice in alt media for the last decade
basically is crazy what Tucker is trying
to do is he's going Ben is my
competition now I'm building out the
Tucker Carlson Network